i mean i mean she's always wanted to get
out of it britney spears
older brother brian opens up about her
conservatorship
it's you know it's very frustrating to
have
whether whether it's someone's coming in
peace to help or
they're coming in with you know an
attitude like having someone constantly
tell you
to do something has got to be
frustrating the rare interview happened
on the as not seen on tv podcast
and took place during a hearing about
the conservatorship
yeah i hear there's a couple hearings i
guess going on right now
um not sure what you know
the details when all that's going to be
but you know
we all hope for the best e.t has learned
that during the hearing which happened
on july 22nd brittany was supposed to
appear via video conference but
it got postponed after unauthorized
parties accessed the court's video
server
my life is kind of like an open book to
the tabloids brian did claim during his
chat that britney does want out of the
conservatorship which was put in place
in 2008 giving their father jamie
control over britney's finances and
personal decisions
if i wasn't under the restraints that
i'm under right now you know with
all the lawyers and doctors and people
analyzing me every day and
all that kind of stuff like if that
wasn't there i'd feel so
liberated and feel like myself
in 2013 brittany told e.t this about her
dating life
the reports of your dad doing a
background check
on david is that not true that is true
that is true yeah
that's crazy yeah does that embarrass
you my dad's a little crazy like that
does he own a gun um he does good
but as for the hashtag free britney
movement and fan theories that britney
needs help escaping her situation
brian had this to say i don't follow it
that well
but i am aware that like they feel like
you know like it's i don't know maybe
she's being confined or something or
held against her will
in some capacity but i can't really i
you know
i'm not i can't speak for them the
conservatorship has been under scrutiny
over the past year with fans wondering
why
38 year old brittany is still under a
legal guardianship
she's been in this thing for quite some
time now obviously there was a need for
it in the beginning
i'm a sagittarius i'm very keen on
freedom i love freedom i love
independence
i don't like to be tied down brittany
and brian's mother lynn recently filed
paperwork to be notified of all matters
regarding britney's finances
the women in this family are very very
strong-minded
and have their own opinion and they want
to do what they want to do
and as much as i admire that as a guy
and being like
one of two guys this entire family it
kind of sucks man
in 2019 a source told et that lin has
always wanted to have a position in
brittany's conservatorship
did i ever manage my children never
did i ever take any percentages of
anything they ever did
no i did not and do i even know how to
broker a deal
people give me way too much credit for
being such a savvy
business person because i really don't
even know how to do these things
hours after brian's interview went live
brittany took to instagram to do a q
a of her own what's my favorite flower
it's a rose and fans think that britney
subtly responded to a comment that her
brother made earlier in the day
she's the worst driver in the world
i'm not lying like like bless her heart
like she really
is not a really good driver have i ever
gotten a speeding ticket i've had
one speeding ticket my whole life
you